you have spent a lot of time reading
about and researching and speaking to
powerful
people who do you think really runs the
world you're going to go there huh with
the question who do I think runs the
world
um so I used to ask the question I said
who who's got the most power in America
is it Congress is it president is it the
cosos of virtual governments we're
talking Google Twitter Facebook you know
those guys Amazon you know or is it
billionaires okay you know the most
richest man in the world who's got the
most power and you'd be amazed how few
people said president cuz they come and
go you know the famous quote with Putin
that he says you know American
Presidents you don't have to worry about
it they're going to be there 4 to8 years
some suits are running you know run the
country behind closed doors and he's got
a very good point when he says something
like that Putin but to me there are a
lot
of alliances being built so if you and I
were to think about aspirational typee
of people okay you know how they say you
know well Michael Jackson eventually got
to a point where we got so many
different girls that he started trying
with this and he started trying with
this and a lot of these people in
Hollywood have so much sex with so many
different people that they become
creative and they do dumb things right
okay Tiger Woods the reason why he got
these girls because what do you know
what it is to be the greatest gol golfer
in the world and everybody throws their
panties at you you want to judge a guy
like that why don't you go be the
greatest golfer and see what it feels
like to be one out of8 billion you don't
know what it's like so they're kind of
trying and experimenting with all this
stuff right it's almost like I'm so much
in a prison jail everybody's watching
what I'm doing I Want to Break The Rules
a little bit to see what I'm capable of
doing okay so so let's go process and
dissect some of these guys that make all
the money in the world okay you become a
billionaire and you're still dangerously
ambitious not from a good place but more
selfish
place okay you took over an industry now
you're worth $5 billion now you're worth
10 if you're a billionaire you're the
best at what you do in your space for
the most part or you help build the best
in that space for the most part Okay
cool
so maybe your marriage didn't work out
maybe you're not the best father in the
world and you're like
well I want more control I want more
power I can't be a president I don't
want to be a president because if I run
for president they're going to reveal
the things that I've done in my life and
God forbid if that gets all the light I
don't want that that's embarrassing but
you know what I'm going to do what if I
can take over the
world are there other people like me
that are driven by wanting to take over
the world what if we could make the
world one place and we make all the
decisions for everybody because I'm
probably one of the smartest people in
the world I'm Pro and you know that
conversation's taking place again you
really start having that Godlike figure
like I don't know if you're familiar
with George Soros you know in one of the
interviews he gave to LA Times he says I
always fancied myself with being a
god fancied myself with being a god this
is an LA Times interview 20 plus years
ago if you Ty in George Soros LA Times
God it's the most disturbing interview
to read about this guy a lot of people
are very skeptical about him right he's
like the boogeyman of a number of
conspiracies how many how many people
have you heard say I always fancied
myself with being a God he says but
what's great about where I'm at right
now is it's no longer a dream became a
reality yeah I have a friend who has
spent a lot of time with super super
powerful people and he told me about a
meeting that he had with one individual
in particular who spoke about being an
apex predator he said that apex
predators don't care about prey and even
though the prey that he was referring to
was still his own
species it was really haunting the story
the way that that was told to me because
you had someone who not only only had
the motivation to be able to go and
enact whatever nefarious malicious plan
but also had the actual resources to be
able to go and do it right those two
things together are they're scary and
that was something that really opened my
eyes I'm very non-c conspiratorial in
the way that I think I I always lean
toward you know do not attribute to
malice that which can be explained by
stupidity do not attribute to
coordination that which can be explained
by coincidence um
and yet the more that I read and the
more that I learn about things the more
there there seems to be there
right yeah you know people are offended
by different
things
[Music]
um some
people being
offended in their deepest
insecurities they're willing to use
their Ambitions to go to certain levels
that at that point they're not thinking
about the consequen of ruining a lot of
people's lives that's not something
they're thinking about at that level so
Hitler was offended when you read MC for
you study what Hitler did he was simply
offended somebody offended him so his
entire life was about doing what he did
just because he was offended now most
people who are offended they do what
they forget about it and they move on
some of these guys want control some of
these guys want to make decisions for
you some of these guys on the money side
at least they go and make money to get
power some people don't go make money to
get power some people CL Schwab they're
like no I'm not going to go make money
to get power I'm going to get power by
creating laws and thinking I know what's
best for you so there's a lot of
different people that you can put in
these steps of organization you just
have to think like if you were to think
about the commission of the mop always
go back to it lucky luchano created a
commission where the five families he
was the one that ran the commission
right of the five families okay when you
think about what meetings in the world
happen happens where all the powerful
people show up you got the
G20 you got the UN you got the world
econom you got Davos you got all these
guys that come together you got NATO you
got so NATO could be like well NATO's
original when the 12 or 14 countries
were part of NATO what was it really all
about to fight USSR there is no USSR why
are we still funding it what's the
outcome now are we still fighting
communism so what a lot of people might
say is that those organizations are so
obvious that they can't be the ones
where the real shit's happening right
that's just the smoke screen the real
is the that's behind it and
the that's behind that and so on
and so forth in your opinion do you
think that NATO WF who that's those
people there's no further upet of
strings that are playing the Ventrilo
quise game behind those ones do you
think that that's where a lot of power
actually
lies um I don't know what I will say
listening to you is with the questions
you're asking I think there's a reason
why the audience wants to hear what you
think about what's going on right now
because you're asking some heavy
questions right now which means you're
curious and if I'm the audience I would
like to know what you can come up with
if you took a deeper dive and really
wanted to get into these types of you
know informations but you
know think about what things people are
most addicted to okay addicted
personalities video games porn sex
cocaine ecstasy
weed steroids
partying all of that
stuff but what's one of the most
addicting
things that many of those guys can't get
power are you kidding me power is like
power porn the porn of having a lot of
power and getting to look in people that
look at you that are afraid of you some
people love that so some people love
that you know the quote like if you
really want to test someone's character
give him power I mean some people really
love having power take a company and see
some of the guys that they hired they
hired a wrong person at the top the guy
was all driven by power what happens
take a president that becomes a
president and he realizes he can use the
justice system against his opponent what
happens they got that power it's a lot
of power to give to somebody right um
yeah so you know those people I believe
are out there some of them are
100% money people because money talks
and you can have a lot of you need funds
to do anything right you do it's it's
going to be the money people um but
there's also the other Power Players
behind closed doors that you know in the
in the movie
Moneyball Jonah Hill plays I don't know
if I'm saying his name correctly he
plays the role of the guy that Brad Pon
saying why is this GM of Cleveland
Indians keeps looking at that
guy doesn't get on BAS who the hell are
you right in in John John Maxwell or or
or Bale Carnegie wrote about this in a
book saying the law of EF Hutton EF
Hutton was in the room that every time
the guy was making a decision he would
have make a decision until he asked
about EF Hutton so so here's we a
proposal okay great hey EF huton what do
you think about it okay we're not going
to be doing it great the world is filled
with e like Henry Kissinger I don't know
how much you know about Henry Kissinger
that guy's an EF Hutton if they ever was
one there's a lot of those
guys that are the brains behind the
faces that we see and most of the times
the best EF huttons no one ever finds
out who they
were no one ever finds out who those
guys are we'll get back to talking to
Patrick in one minute but first I need
to tell you about
element element contains a science
backed electrolyte ratio of sodium
potassium and magnesium with no junk no
coloring no artificial ingredients or
any other BS it is a healthy alternative
to sugary electrolyte drinks and it's
how I've started my morning every single
day for over 3 years now you don't need
coffee first thing in the morning your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active for the first 90
minutes of the day but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system best of all they have a nobs no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy it and try it completely
risk-free and if you do not like it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box right now you can get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box by going to the link in
the description below or heading to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom that's drink
LM nt.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Patrick then press here for the
fulllength over 2our long podcast go on
give it a
press